[Music]
doctor doctor get in here quick
is everything all right the coma patient
sir he's woke what no he's not awake no
no it's not that he's awake is that he's
woke see even though he's asleep he's
somehow aware of all the social
injustice as black people are facing
every day that's why he's wearing his
sweet-ass blacklivesmatter shirt
actually all eyes matter what I'm a
doctor I took an oath oh wait a minute
he's got a voting ballot from 2014 and
he wrote in Rachel Dolezal don't you
know he didn't know none of us knew back
then oh he's getting a call from Erica
Budd knew this dude as well cos
wait I don't understand how does he know
what's going on well I'm glad you asked
that it's not just about seeing and
hearing being woke is a feeling deep
inside the human heart
he's right injustice anywhere is a
threat to justice everywhere oh my god
you're awake and you used to care about
such trivial but now you probably
don't care that girls just ended what
girls you bastard why'd you have to say
that man such a Marnie
[Music]
you